il reste un mystère pour de nombreux
médecins du monde entier mais il a un
nom le qu'ovide long pour de nombreux
malades le coc u19 a été l' affaire de
quelques jours mais pour d'autres les
symptômes durent depuis plusieurs mois
voici comment la haute autorité de santé
présentent en france ce qu'est le coc
vie de long la haute autorité de santé
utilise le terme de symptômes prolongé
suite à la copie de 10,9 il s'agit de
symptômes qui persiste au delà de quatre
semaines après la date présumée de
contamination et qui ne sont pas dus à
une autre maladie le plus souvent il y a
plusieurs symptômes ils peuvent être
différentes d'une personne à l'autre et
d'intensités différentes l'existence de
covile ont fait l'objet d'un consensus
dans le monde médical en revanche les
causes de la persistance des symptômes
et leurs conséquences restent
aujourd'hui un grand flou pour tenter
d'en savoir plus l'université d'oxford a
mené une étude sur le sujet les dossiers
de plus de deux cent soixante treize
mille survivants du coït 19 habitants
principalement aux états unis qui ont
été examinés
cette étude a utilisé les données des
dossiers de santé électroniques de 273
1618 patients diagnostiqués qu'ovide 19
et a estimé le risque d'avoir des
caractéristiques kovy 19 dans les six
mois suivant un diagnostic de kovy de 19
l'étude a comparé le risque de
caractéristiques de longue durée de kovy
dedans différents groupes de la
population et a également comparé ce
même risque après une grippe selon les
résultats de cette étude les symptômes
prolongée de la maladie sont plus
fréquents chez les anciens malades
ducobu de 19 que chez ceux de la grippe
pendant les six mois qui suivent leur
contamination au covit 19 ils sont 57% à
présenter encore un ou plusieurs
symptômes ducobu 19 l'étude a révélé que
plus dans patient sur trois présenter
une ou plusieurs caractéristiques de
covile ont enregistré entre trois et six
mois après un diagnostic de kobe de 19
ce taux était significativement plus
élevé qu'après la grippe le coc u19
semble être associé à des effets à long
terme qui sont communs et divers avec 57
% des patients ayant au moins une
caractéristique du coc vide l'on
enregistré dans les 180 jours après
l'infection et 37% les ayants dans les
90 à 180 jours après le diagnostic dont
40 % n'en avais pas eu dans les trois
premiers mois les chercheurs restent
cependant
prudence selon eux l'étude laissent
penser que l'origine de ces symptômes
persistants pourrait être en partie liés
à une infection au virus du coc vide
toujours est il que certains malades ont
vu leur vie bouleversée en raison de ce
qu vinh long en belgique par exemple une
association de malades demandent une
reconnaissance officielle du coville
long comme maladie professionnelle